I wanted to be a comedian from the age of about 13,
14, you know? Um, and then I, I,
I did it two times,
three times when I was 17 and one time I did it and it went
really well. And the,
and it was the comedy store in Sydney and you have to go down there and they put
your name in a hat and they pull your name out.
And I had five minutes and it was just all about being in school or whatever.
I can't even remember what I talked about. And, um, uh, then they said, Oh,
you're not 18. I, and I was like, nah. And they go,
you have to come back with a parent.
And so I hadn't told my parents and my parents as well.
I hadn't even told them that I went into the city.
Like I wasn't allowed to go into the city. You know,
I lived out in the suburbs and I told them I went to a mate's house or
something. So I traveled into the city and, um, uh, so,
so next on army dad had to come with me and I remember it was like bucketing
down with rain.
And I went out there and I got back on and the only other people in the
audience, cause it was raining where the other comedians waiting to go on.
And there was the full range of people who were getting good at it.
People who would never going to get good at it and people who their first go and
people had been trying for years. And anyway, I got up,
I couldn't have had a worst gig.
I couldn't have died worse than that. And I got in the car with me,
dad afterwards, and me dad said, uh, you guys are,
you're a good kid and you got a lot of good qualities, but, uh,
but this isn't for you and I, my heart sank. And I,
then I went and did it one more time just to see,
cause at first I went so well and then I did it again and I died again.
And I went, all right, this isn't for me.
And then I didn't go up again until I was 20. I didn't do it. Yeah.
I waited another three years. I just think it was more than that.
But I was in college and I used to run my own comedy night.
And I remember there was a, there was a,
I was in Perth when I started doing that.
So a lot of people think I'm from Perth because of this,
because I really started doing comedy in Perth. But, um, I, I th I, the,
the way that a lot of people get stage time is what you do is you find a venue,
you put your own shows on you, book your own comedians,
and that way you can emcee and you can get better by, you know,
cause I couldn't get gigs. So I thought I'd run my own gig. And there was,
there was this area in Perth called Claremont and Claremont,
um, had a, a serial killer at the time.
Declare.
Had the claim on killer. All right. So what happened?
I don't think they ever caught him. I don't know,
but maybe they did catch him on. I know, but when I was there,
that guy called the Claremont killer.
And what happened was with the claim on killer, all the,
all the bars that were normally, this was a big potty area of Perth.
They were all, no one was going out because all the girls who got killed,
the last thing that happened for them,
they left the nightclub and got into a taxi and went looking for a taxi and then
they were never seen again. So that, that nightlife there just died.
So there was all these like bars that were just empty.
And so I went into one like, Oh, can I have a gig?
And they were just happy to have anyone in the building.
And I used to get like 15 people, me mates to come along to these shows.
And it was like a really popular bar.
But on a Friday night I could have a gig there because of the killer. So,
you know, silver lining to what happened there.
And when you, if we go back to 17, you tried it three times,
maybe this isn't for me,
what in your head was plan B or the alternative?
Well, th th there's a weird thing sort of, I think there's a,
you know, for people who really know about me and there's just not many people,
but there's, there's a bit of a, a myth about me being an opera singer,
um, which is, is vaguely true. Right?
What happened was when I was 17,
I was in a school musical and then I was doing all right. And then someone said,
Oh, you should get some singing lessons and blah, blah, blah.
And so I got some singing lessons with this guy called Richard Gill,
who has since passed.
And he was one of the main conductors for the Sydney opera. And he, he, um,
he got me, he, he got me a part in the chorus of, uh, of,
uh, Wagner as the flying Dutchman. And I had to sing in German. I was like 17.
And I just sang, I just, I just bought a CD of this, this opera.
And I just mimicked it, you know? And I, I, I wasn't that greatest singer,
but after that, I, I, I, um, I got into, uh,
WaPo,
which is the Western Australian Academy of performing arts and I studied musical
theater. And then I studied operating the next year. And so, so I,
I was a professional opera singer for a few weeks of my life, but it was never,
it was never a full thing, but I did this course.
It was the same course that Hugh Jackman did. And it was like,
it was a full scholarship ride.
And I remember because I didn't have the marks in school to get into anything
academic in university.
And I don't believe I had the marks to actually get into this course,
but they never checked my, for my high school certificate.
And I just went in and did a dance and singing audition and stuff.
And I always still wanted to be a comic,
but because I thought the comedy wouldn't work out,
I still wanted to be an entertainer and a performer. So I thought, ah,
this is another thing I can do. And it was also,
I think for my mother at that stage,
that was something that she was far happier to brag about,
that I was studying music in a prestigious college or something like that.
But on maybe my second year into the course,
there was a comedian called Gary who, who is like a,
this guy who had been on Australian TV. I'm still,
I still know Gary to this day. He's very nice, man. And, uh,
he'd come over to do a gig in Perth. And I was his opening act. Then we had,
we had a few drinks afterwards. We got along.
I think he liked me more as a person than he liked me as a comic. But he said,
he said, do you want to come and do these, these, um, mining town gigs?
And I thought, Oh, I thought, ah, that's too good, an opportunity.
So I quit university.
And I went out to like places like cow goalie and these little gold mining
towns. And I performed in these bars just to like Australian Cowboys,
pretty much like guys in cowboy hats,
they live out in the land and they work in the mines and all these towns had so
many men working out there.
And so few women that in the bars, in these towns,
the bartender would be a female and they'd be,
and they'd ship them in and they'd call them skimpy peas and a skimpy.
And she would just be topless. Now, th th this wasn't,
this wasn't, um, a strip bar. This was just a normal bar.
All the bars have topless bartenders in all these, um, little country towns.
And the reason for that is if you take away the topless,
go behind the bar, it's a guy bar.
It's just, it's just men. So, so they had to go, nah, we're not a guy.
Cause they will dress like Cowboys. Just the only thing that we're not gay,
there's a pair of over there. So where, all right. You know,
and so I did these gigs and I thought, and I had,
I hadn't told my parents that I'd quit university. I thought, you know,
I thought I'll just keep doing this until I can be a full-time comic.
And then I think it's basically the storyline of the movie,
punchline that Tom Hanks character who said, uh, he said, Oh no,
I'm going to be a doctor. I'm going to be a doctor. And then he said,
he'd tell his parents once he's a professional coming. But then I just quit uni.
I went back to Sydney, to my pants and said, I'm going to give standup comedy,
a guy. And then I think I moved to England. Oh, I moved to England then,
um, I know the day I moved in then because, um,
I was packing my suitcase and about 10 o'clock at night
and I was all excited. It was going to be my first time traveling overseas.
I'd never been, I know I tell a lot. I'd been to America once when I was 14,
but it was my first time traveling overseas by myself without family members
yet. And I was going on me, big adventure barmy sofa.
I was getting on a plane and, uh, and uh, I was packing me bags and the,
and the twin towers fell down. And that's when I, that's how I can.
That's how I can remember the date that I left for Britain the next day. Yeah.